our next speaker Gavin Schmidt is a
climatologist and climate model are from
NASA Goddard Institute for Space Studies
at Columbia University and his work uses
models that are large-scale atmosphere
ocean systems that test climate
variability future climate variability
under a warmer world as well as the
character of ancient climates in 2004
Scientific American magazine awarded him
the top 50 scientists of the year it's a
prestigious award I don't think it came
with any cash that it coming in and
they've cancelled it something it
doesn't come with any cash you know it's
very nice but it was a one-off anyway
this morning talk is a Camry constrained
future hydrologic changes by looking to
the past oh well thank you very much I
like asking me okay we're back um I'm
going to give you a talk that that has a
question at the end and that's generally
the the sign that we haven't actually
finished this work and so we're not
she's going to come to any conclusions
and that that would be a appropriate
conclusion that you can draw right now
um one of the things that we do at I
mean I work for NASA and a so is not
generally very interested in paleo
climate but it is very interested in
hydroplaning it's very interested in
future projections it's very interested
in understanding what's going on right
now and to do that we build models but
models when you go out into the future
there's a very very large changes and we
need to find ways to test how credible
those models are and so by looking into
the past that's really one of the ways
that we can do
so it's going to work yes so we're not
the first people to think of this of
course James Hutton was the first person
to really express this and he said from
what has actually been we have data for
concluding with regard to that which is
to happen thereafter possibly not the
the prettiest demonstration of this
thing Steven Spielberg did a much better
job a couple of centuries later and this
is the real issue were going back to
look at the future and then you have to
ask yourself why do we need what how do
we look at the future right we look at
the future and we generally look at the
future through models and there was a
very nice quote from from Tomlinson gfdl
and he said this isn't in response to a
particularly stupid comments on one of
his papers I said well if we had our
reservations in the future we obviously
would trust them more than the models
but unfortunately observations of the
future and not available at this time
and so when we're going into the future
we have to rely on models so the big
question I'm looking into the future is
how do we judge the credibility of those
models what is robust that comes out of
those models what is important on what
other things that are actionable right
models are not good because they're
complicated models are not good because
we've worked on them for 30 years models
are good because they produce credible
predictions that can be validated if you
look at the IPCC report of the last time
around and you ask yourself well what
kind of uncertainties arose from that
there was there was obviously tons of
discussion about uncertainties but I
particularly like this figure arm this
is a change of rainfall changes in 2100
under one of the the mid-range scenarios
are compared to compared to the present
and it shows
the multi-model average rainfall change
was so they took the 27 odd models and
they took all of their different results
and they averaged all of those results
together and and that's that's the the
color scale that you get there the scale
doesn't really matter because the
pattern is very similar regardless of
what scenario you look at and there's
some very clear patterns here you have
an increase in in rainfall right along
the equator we have an increase in
precipitation in the in the high
latitudes both in the in the southern
hemisphere and in the northern
hemisphere and then in the subtropics
you have this this dryer zone this is
the yellows and oranges where is really
we're seeing an expansion of the Hadley
circulation and expansion of the
subsiding dry areas and and this looks
coherent and almost all the models have
a pattern that looks like this but when
you look in detail and you ask yourself
well how how much do the models they
disagree amongst themselves this is
that's how it gets very interesting and
now the black dots here which you can
see there's a lot of black dots here
there's not very many over here these
black dots are an indication of model
agreement like to what extent this
pattern is a robust response to the
forcing so all this stuff down here in
the southern hemisphere in a southern
high latitudes that's robust right all
of the models show an increase in
precipitation there are the same thing
for the for the changes right on the
equator and enemy and there are good
physical reasons for this right the
increase in precipitation in the polls
is because water vapor is being is
converging towards the poles there's
more water vapor in the atmosphere it
has to go somewhere and it comes out as
rain or snow increases in rainfall right
on the equator associated with increases
in tropical convection and that produces
cool ring ah but then you look at then
you look a little bit more closely and
you look at most of the u.s. you look at
the Amazon you look at the Sahel you
look at India you look at Australia and
there are no dots now what that means is
the models are schizophrenic it means
that maybe half of them in some cases
actually showing that it's going to get
wetter and half of them are showing that
it's going to get drier so our ability
to make a statement about how robust the
model result is there is if there is no
ability to make that statement and so
that was how many people live in those
areas that's that's maybe a billion
people live in those areas and we have
no idea anymore 22 billion people living
as Earth and we have no idea what to
tell them from from all of our modeling
studies about how they're Hydra climbing
is going to change that's profoundly
disquieting right that's that's that's
bothersome um but this this area is also
interesting because their areas that
have a rich history of paleo climate
studies and observations of change for
instance you know the Sahara you know we
know that it was much greener during the
mid Holocene 6,000 years ago we know
that in America we've got a great
drought record from this network of
trees in Australia we have Kate records
and in India we have K records and all
sorts of other things that tell us how
rainfall changed what how rainfall
patterns changed in the past and so the
question is can we do a better job than
just averaging all the models together
even the ones that seem to produce
completely contradictory answers and I
think the answer is yes so we have been
involved in this project called seem it
fine which has been a project that has
taken our time and effort for about the
last two years twenty-four/seven that
entire
time we're not the only group that's
been doing these runs and car gfdl the
Met Office in the UK the the climate
modelers in in France Korea Japan
Germany roughly 30 plus institutions
have been doing these simulations and
these simulations are a whole package of
different things you have the future
projections that's all these are CP
things so the RCB 8.5 which carry
briefly alluded to that's a very very
strong forcing if that ever happens
literally we're toast RCP 4.5 is a kind
of more moderate scenario RCP to point x
or sometimes it's called ICP three this
is this is a very optimistic sorry oh
that assumes that by the end of the
century we are sucking carbon out of the
atmosphere at a prodigious rate so
that's not going to happen either RCP
six is somewhere in between 8.5 and 4.5
um they're all scenarios they're not
predictions of what's going to happen in
the future they're all kind of story
lines but what might happen they span a
wide range of carbon dioxide levels but
they don't span a very wide range of
things like aerosols or biomass burning
or something like that so they're not a
full suite of things that could happen
but they are suggestive but the but it
but in this in this suite of runs
there's also a whole set of paleo
climate runs and this is the first time
that we have ever self-organized in this
way where we brought in the people who
are interested in the future and the
people were interested in the past and
made them do all the same sets of
experiments with the same models with
the same database with the same
diagnostic in the same formats so if
you're interested in whether anything in
the future correlates to anything in the
past up until now you had a very very
hard job but right now your job suddenly
got a lot easier and when things get
easier you can do much more interesting
research so I'm just going to give you a
couple of of examples of the things
that people are doing to demonstrate its
worth but first of all I mean let me ask
the question why do we really care about
paleo coming I alluded to it before but
the main issue is that future climate
change is out of sample right we have
observations the last 30 years that are
really good last 50 years which are okay
going back a little bit further you know
it gets much worse much very quickly but
the changes that we've seen over those
periods are tiny compared to the changes
we're projecting for the 24 the 28 end
of the 21st century right so those
changes are out of sample compared to
anything then calibrate against that's
why statistical models on their own are
not going to be very useful it turns out
that when you try and rank the models
based on how well they do against
observations that we have for today
whether it's the seasonal cycle whether
it's a sponsor El Nino where it's
interannual variability whether it's
storming or anything these things are
not correlated to what the models say is
going to happen in the future you can
have one model that has the most perfect
seasonal cycle and another model which
has the worst seasonal cycle compared to
the observations and they'll both
produce the same change going forward
into the future and so getting the
seasonal cycle right doesn't tell you
whether your model is going to give you
the right answer in the written in the
in the future paleo climate and
particularly the pair of climates were
looking at here is not an analog for
what's going to happen in the future
what we're going to has never happened
before the history of the planet right
but a lot of the changes that happened
in the past are changes that exercise
the same machinery the same processes
that we're pushing in various directions
in the future were pushed in slightly
different directions with slightly
different combinations in the past and
so if you think about like taking a car
act for a test drive going around the
block before you head off on a
cross-country trip that's the kind of
thing that we're looking at um and you
know I mentioned that you know you need
to have these coordinated comparisons
and that requires a lot of work and it's
taken us a number of decades to get that
far it needs coordinated databases
for the pain no data it needs
improvements in the in the archives
which we've now kind of got to and we
need to connect the Paleo to the kind of
future projections and that's and that's
what we've done inseam it five like I
said for the first time since we've been
doing this so with pea simulations you
can do three kinds of things right and
most people only think about the first
so the I'll just kind of skip further
skip through that really um if you do a
climate simulation the lgm the most
interesting thing for most people is to
say oh well can you explain what
happened at the last special maximum you
know what happened here what happened
there what was the size of the ice
sheets how did that affect this and
there's lots of people in the
paleoclimate community who think that
that's why we should be doing paleo
simulations okay I work for NASA and let
me tell you this does not fly in any
proposal meeting that you're with where
you have somebody from NASA who's paying
for the bill nobody cares a NASA why the
last actual maximum looked the way it
did right so all of these different
studies most of what goes into pay
oceanography most of what goes into
climate in the past is completely not of
interest to most funders in in the US
but there's two other things that you
can do which are far more interesting
one is to find metrics that co here
between the past and the present so what
you're doing is you're trying to find
things that okay well in the past there
was this relationship between these
variables and in the future the model
suggested that relationship is the same
and we have for the past some evidence
that that relationship is actually be
incredibly modeled right and then that
gives you a way of kind of projecting
that credibility into the future the
third thing that you can do is is where
i live to before is to differentiate
between models to differentiate between
models that appear to have skill when
you're looking at the min holla scene or
you're looking at the last millennium
and hopefully showing that that skill
projects onto a difference
future prediction and that way if you
have models which are more skillful or
less skillful but they give you a
different answer in the future you might
then wait your prediction for the future
towards the models that have more skill
in the past and I'll give you examples
of both of those last two things but
here's just a sense of what kind of
things you know this is six different
models that have done a whole suite of
experiments so these top two rows are
for global warming experiments and
abrupt rise in full-time co2 one percent
increase in co2 you know I've been there
kind of cleaner comparisons and the RCP
experiments but they're begging you
pretty much the same answer this is for
temperature of course this is the
seasonality the change between the wall
and the cold seasons and then this is
the mean annual temperature the monthly
color the monthly the maximum
temperature in the coal month maximum
temperature in the world month and then
these six row five rows here this is the
20th century runs this is the min
Holocene 6,000 years ago and this is the
last glacial maximum and if you don't
look at anything else on this little
graph and look at this if you look at
the seasonality change associated with a
warming world and you look at the
seasonality change associated with a
cooling world there's there's a there's
a kind of mirror image going on there
right there are connections between how
the models respond to cold as they
respond to warm it's not it's not linear
it's not simple when it and it's not
universal but there are connections if
you compare those multimodal seen
ensembles to the actual data this is
that this is the historical changes and
then this is the model estimate of the
historical changes arm just I mean I
should cut all
stuff actually you look at the mid
Holocene you can see that you know
there's a lot more actually this is true
for in all of the data seeds there's a
lot more heterogeneity in the data then
there is the model means that you expect
because you're averaging over a lot of
variability within the models but
there's also a lot of noise in the data
right data from from paleoclimate is not
as good as data from satellites and
where the stations today but you can see
that we've got quite a lot of data for
the men have seen we have quite a lot of
data for the lgm and you can't really
see how well this works out especially
because the this is all kind of washed
out because everything is in the fight
and in a minus 5 2-10 category but we do
have enough data to start to constrain
the spatial patterns so let's look for
some robust metrics let's look for
things which are which which look the
same in the past and the same in the
future okay so here's Andy here's an
example this is the temperature gradient
are from north to south and then this is
the the shift in the ITCZ right and this
is a whole bunch of different models
both in future experiments and in past
experiments and what it shows there's a
relationship right it says that the ITCZ
will move as a function of changes in
the changes in the in that in the
temperature gradient in ways that are
actually quite predictable right that's
a good thing right because we can then
say okay well if we know the sea surface
temperature changes are going to be 0 we
can say what the itcz how that's going
to move and that's obviously is very
important for a hydro car here are some
other examples right the land ocean
contrast in temperature right here are
all the different models for three
different periods the historical mid
holla scene and the lgm these are the
lgm ones here this is the mid holstein
historical and you can see that the land
ocean contrast and the observations are
these these big crosses
and you can see them got some
observations there as well and you can
see that when you pull all the models
together there are relationships between
the land ocean contrast that are the
same and credible in the lgm as they are
in the as they are in the future and the
present the same thing is true for polar
amplification the same thing is true for
seasonality though though slightly
slightly less Celeste feeling right so
there are things that you can look at
property property plots that you can
look at in the models that handicap
there can be credibly tested in the
Paleo climate data but also our constant
through all of the different model
simulations are here's another example
and this is the temperature change
between the North Atlantic in Europe and
again here are the future runs here at
the past runs this is the estimate from
payoh data reconstructions themselves
and you can see that the models they
don't match everything perfectly but the
relationship between the North Atlantic
and European temperatures is quite
clearly the same relationship that we
see in the in the new constructions
right so we have something that the
models do get correct even if they don't
get the same amplitude as we're
inferring from the data so this raises a
question when when you kind of try and
differentiate the models right all of
that stuff that I just showed you was
where all the models look the same but
we don't just want all the models to
look the same because we saw on the on
the first rainfall map the lots of
models differ in very important regions
or types and how do you differentiate
between the moles okay so what you need
is you need some measure of skill and it
doesn't matter what it is it can be in
frequency space it can be
no it can be global it can be whatever
variable you like where you have some
some data and then you what's what
you're looking for is a correlation of
that skill are with some future change
so quite often you've seen this kind of
person where you have lots of different
measures of skill from the different
models but it actually doesn't correlate
to the future right so this skill that's
good not good okay four buttons on here
quite frankly that's too many what
you're looking for is a skill measure
that correlates to this because right
here what you're finding is that
whatever future changed these models are
predicting it's not correlated to this
skill measure and so this skill measure
is orthogonal to the reasons why it's
giving the future change that it is
right it becomes not useful what you're
looking for is something like this where
you have a correlation or a structure to
the future change skill relationship are
that you can use because now you can say
ah well you know let's imagine that this
is higher skill then this might be more
likely to be the futures change right
now the weird thing is that almost
everybody works as if all metrics look
like this but the number of people who
actually test that this is actually the
situation that you have is very very
small and so if you ever do anything
like this please check that your skill
metric actually does correlate to the
future change rather than just assuming
it so here's a here's an example that we
talked about in a recent paper that's
currently under open review so if you
have anything to say about what I'm
about to say you can write an angry
comments that everybody can read what
we're looking at here is what's going on
in South America right that was one of
those areas where there weren't very
many dots and the reason why there
aren't very many dots is that the model
was kind of fall into two groups in fact
they fall into three groups but it is to
which
quite quite clear if you look at the
first group and this is these are these
are the future predictions compared to
compared to the present you see that
there's one group that says we're going
to have a lot more this is a lot drier
here and this is a lot wetter right so
we have this kind of dipole across the
top of North America and there's another
group which says no that's not going to
happen at all it's going to be wetter
there and dryer here and this is a very
different pattern and they're related to
a one group of models just shifts just
shifts the itcz and another group of
model really expands the ITCZ and
there's different processes that are
going on in different balances that are
happening um and if you look at what
those same models did for the for the
mid holla seen what you find is that the
models that have this kind of dipole
structure for the future also have this
same dipole structure for the for the
mid policy and the models that had just
a shift in the ITCZ also had something
that looked similar to that in the mid
Holocene and if you are if you correlate
that and you say okay well what's the
relationship between that change in the
dipole in the mud in the mid holla scene
and the change in the dipole in the
future you do see this relationship
right so what we have here is the
possibility of looking at the data and
saying okay well which group of these
models is more realistic what actually
happened in the in the mid holla scene
and can we say that it's more like these
models or it's more like these models
and it turns out that there's a there's
a there's a data synthesis that's
impress I think that that suggests that
the the group one models are more
realistic so that that would be these
two up here which if we go back that's
this kind of pattern here so that would
be suggestive that you're going to
expect drier conditions northern South
America and then weather conditions in
the Nordic
okay so I think these are the kinds of
things that we should be doing we should
be doing much much more often one of the
things that we've worked on particularly
guess is including more proxies of
what's actually being measured in the
past one of the key measurements that
you use our water isotopes in carbonates
these are records from cave records from
Borneo Sulawesi and Flores in the in the
western Pacific warm pool and you can
see there's been this large shift this
is the early holocene here moving to the
present this has been a large shift our
kind of flight from about ten thousand
to about 5,000 BP in all of those places
and when you put that into the model and
you ask okay what was what it what of
the isotopes in rainfall changed like
what you get is a big shift of around
you know one to two people which
actually matches is data really really
well so when it turns out that the water
isotope change is very related to how
water is shifting right where water is
coming from so if you're getting more
tropical source water or you're getting
more water from from the east or west
pacific these have signatures in the
isotopes which are directly tied to the
to the hydrological cycle if not they're
not directly tied to local precipitation
but they are can tied to large-scale
changes increase in in the hydrological
cycle of the tropics some metrics are
not robust you know we can look at
things and we can say okay we've got a
great correlation in the past our but
the correlation the future breaks down
now one of those is the pds I write a
polymer drought severity index because
of the large temperature component in
the standard version of that index you
can have models show a really nice
correlation between this is soil
moisture and then this is the pds I this
is over North America they show a very
strong correlation which you can't
really see it's kind of obscure but
the correlation is quite strong in the
historical and past millennium runs but
it breaks down completely when you go
into the future records right Parma
drought severity index it's it's a an
index which is based on a model of how
evaporation works which is not very
accurate and and the idea is that when
you have a very negative PDS I then your
drag conditions in a very positive PDS I
you're in wet kind of fuel conditions
and and there are records of pds either
have been derived from tree rings from a
whole network across the north north
america for instance so that's there's a
the nada people the nada PDS I that's
here so you can't really quite see but
there's a the ups and downs are about
the same size as the models predict but
they're not coherent right one of the
things that you that we've just started
to see is that the models will produce
kind of mega droughts in North America
around at the right frequency are but
they're kind of uncorrelated to any
forces one of those random things that's
happening oh so there's some very
interesting stuff it but but if you take
it forward if you say okay well my PDS I
is going to change dramatically in the
future that doesn't necessarily mean
that you're saw moisture is going to
disappear and that you're going to be in
some huge tract condition and these are
two models are where you can see this
very strong divergence between the soil
moisture and the PSI in the future and
in completely opposite directions right
so here this this model is saying a
whether North America this model is
saying kind of about the same North
America but the PDS I indices would
indicate that North America was in some
absolutely unprecedented direct
situation so you've got to be a little
bit care so let me conclude I think it's
it's quite important people to realize
that the multi-model ensemble actually
does a pretty good job at simulating the
key periods that we've looked at for the
Paleo planet that we've that's the mid
Holocene 68 years ago the last glacial
maximum 20
years ago in the last thousand years so
from the medieval period to ER to the
present and it's very important that you
realize that these are out of sample
tests nobody in any of the modeling
groups twiddled with their models in
order to get a better lgm right just
it's for practical reasons it's
impossible for us to do there are many
climate features and relations between
climate features that are robust between
the past and the future that is an
absolutely key insight there are
constraints therefore on hydro climate
going into the future which we're just
beginning to explore and publish on and
there's going to be a lot more work done
on this in the next few years we can see
that there are going to be shifts in icc
Z as a function of SST gradients that's
a robust result we can distinguish
between models for instance in the South
American case between models that got
that dipole change right in the mid
holla scene and who also predict a
dipole like change in rainfall in the
future and those seem to be more
credible than models that don't have
that pattern in the past and so instead
of doing the multi-model mean for
ensemble for the Amazon you know we can
actually say okay well those models over
there we're not going to pay much
attention to those we're going to down
weight them and we have a credible way
of doing that people have been looking
at the mega droughts particularly in
North America they do seem to be modeled
in the GCMs these that these are things
that the models are capable of producing
but as yet we haven't found any reason
to think that they're being driven by
any external forcing they could just one
of those internal things now that might
not that that conclusion might not be
sustained but right now that seems to be
the conclusion that we have and the key
thing is is a lot more work to do if
your people who have
not really looked at GCM data before or
you thought that it was too complicated
or you thought that it wasn't an i asked
question there wasn't going to be able
to answer the questions that you have
think again the same at five archive is
an absolute treasure trove it's roughly
three petabytes of data it's the third
largest distributed archive of
information in the world after CERN and
google it is an enormous resource and
the number of people who are looking at
it and the number of things that could
be done with it are vastly out of
proportion and so if you're looking for
a good project for a student if you're
looking for an interesting things or
what about this look at this archive and
there's there's I can't promise that
it's perfect but it's a huge resource
that that deserves to be looked at far
more closely so I'll just I'll just
leave you with with a parting thought I
prediction is difficult and actually not
just at the future but also in the past
and and you know the task that we've
been appointed to do is a real challenge
and but nobody said it was going to be
easy but we can we can still do better
than when doing some of you might
remember a really terrible model
terrible a terrible movie called The Day
After Tomorrow desert there's a scene
where they're all in the climate model
control room and somebody comes in grid
morals can't save us now and actually I
that that's the only line in the movie
that was actually true
and anyway so well so that's about it I
got books I tweet this is new tweeting
anyway so that's one thank you very much